INTRO:
If you’ve ever watched a video about the
stock market, you’ve likely heard the term
Nasdaq, but it’s often used in significantly
different contexts.
Sometimes, people are referring to an index
like the S&P 500 or the Dow Jones.
Othertimes, people are referring to a stock
exchange similar to the NYSE or the London
Stock Exchange.
And in other cases, people are talking about
a publicly traded company called the Nasdaq.
Given all these different definitions, it’s
easy to write off the Nasdaq as just some
other gear in the financial markets.
But, the Nasdaq is actually the lifeblood
of the biggest tech companies in the world
including Apple, Microsoft, Amazon, Tesla,
Nvidia, and Google.
What’s even crazier is that the NASDAQ is
by no means a heritage player in the stock
market.
In fact, the NASDAQ wasn’t even created
till 1971.
For perspective, the NYSE was founded in 1792.
Despite this short history, the NASDAQ has
become the king of the modern stock market.
So here’s exactly what the NASDAQ is and
how it squashed legacy players to the top.
COMPANY:
Starting with the origins of the NASDAQ, we
have the company behind everything.
The story of the company dates back to the
late 1960s when Wall Street was struggling
to keep up with demand.
This was because the 1960s was one of the
most prosperous times in the US.
The economy was booming, wages were skyrocketing,
and GDP growth was through the roof.
In fact, real GDP growth averaged 5% throughout
the 1960s and US payrolls increased by 32%.
To top it all of, the US would reach the moon
near the end of the decade so the everyday
American was feeling more confident than ever
before leading them to take a dabble with
the stock market.
At the time, the go to exchange to buy stocks
was the New York Stock Exchange or the NYSE.
This drove unprecedented amounts of volume
into the NYSE.
By the start of the 1970s, the average daily
trading volume was 12 million shares per day.
This might not sound like much compared to
the billions of shares that are traded on
a daily basis today, but given that the NYSE
was only open for 5 hours per day in the early
1970s, we’re talking about executing 667
shares every single second.
While this was great for business, the NYSE
had extremely difficulty handling all these
trades.
After all, they didn’t get any help from
computers, so they had to manually execute
and keep track of every trade that took place.
Seeing this rapidly compounding issue, the
National Association of Securities Dealers
or the NASD decided to create an electronic
stock market called the NASDAQ or the National
Association of Securities Dealers Automated
Quotations.
And this gave rise to the world’s first
electronic stock market on February 8, 1971.
In the beginning, the NASDAQ wasn’t exactly
an electronic stock market per se given that
they didn’t actually execute any trades
electronically.
Rather, they were more of a quotation service
that allowed investors to electronically see
the live prices of the various stocks listed
on the platform.
When it came to actually executing trades,
however, this was still done manually.
But, it didn’t take long for the NASDAQ
to introduce electronic execution as well.
STOCK EXCHANGE:
Over the next few decades, the NASDAQ introduced
one feature after another from automatically
tracking daily volume to the electronic execution
of trades.
Given the relative ease of the NASDAQ stock
exchange, a lot of investors and especially
traders flocked towards the exchange.
By the early 1980s, the NASDAQ accounted for
37% of the entire US securities market and
it wasn’t long before the crossed the 50%
mark.
But, despite the extreme popularity of the
NASDAQ, it was never that respected.
In fact, the NASDAQ was often referred to
as an OTC market or an over-the-counter market.
If you’re not familiar with this term, it
basically refers to the trading of stocks
that aren’t listed on the major stock exchanges
such as the American Stock Exchange or the
NYSE.
The term OTC is generally used with a negative
connotation as it’s closely related to the
trading of garbage penny stocks.
Despite this negative association, some up
and coming tech companies like Microsoft and
Apple who understood the power of electronic
trading started to embrace the NASDAQ.
This didn’t change the perception of the
NASDAQ overnight, but it did cause investors
to take the NASDAQ more seriously.
After all, Microsoft and Apple were by no
means penny stocks.
The Apple IPO, for example, minted 40 millionaires
and made Steve Jobs a centimillionaire.
Throughout the rest of the century, the NASDAQ
dominated the tech IPO scene and they made
ground breaking progress within the financial
markets.
For example, in 1992, the NASDAQ partnered
with the London Stock Exchange which marked
the first time that the capital markets of
different continents were linked together.
But unfortunately, as the millennium came
to a close, so did the NASDAQ’s positive
reputation at least for the short term.
You see, in the early 2000s, we saw one of
the most painful stock market crashes in history
called the dotcom crash.
Fortunately, everyday people weren’t really
affected by this crash and most of them don’t
even know this took place.
But, if you were invested in tech companies,
you got slaughtered.
And given that basically every tech company
you can think of was listed on the NASDAQ,
the NASDAQ become associated with extreme
speculation and massive losses.
While this wasn’t a great situation for
the NASDAQ, they continued to push forward
the financial markets by leveraging the internet.
In 1998, the NASDAQ became the first US exchange
to offer online trading.
And the NASDAQ started using the slogan “the
stock market for the next hundred years.”
The NASDAQ also started acquiring and partnering
with a bunch of foreign exchanges and they
rebranded these as NASDAQ exchanges.
This led to the rise of NASDAQ Copenhagen,
NASDAQ Stockholm, NASDAQ Helsinki, NASDAQ
Iceland, and so on and so forth.
So, in the end, the company NASDAQ is simply
a conglomeration of stock exchanges from around
the world.
But, as we discussed in the beginning, this
is not the only thing that they’re known
for.
INDICES:
If people aren’t referring to the company
or the exchange when the say NASDAQ, they’re
likely referring to the NASDAQ indices.
Similar to the S&P 500 and the Dow Jones,
the NASDAQ offers a few indices that have
grown to be quite popular.
The two most popular NASDAQ indices are the
NASDAQ composite index and the NASDAQ 100.
People often get confused between these two
and their nearly identical prices doesn’t
exactly help with this situation, but there
is a major difference.
The NASDAQ composite index was founded alongside
the company way back in 1971.
And this index tracks all of the equity securities
that are listed on the NASDAQ stock market
which includes over 2500 stocks.
Initially, the index was launched with a price
of $100 and given that the NASDAQ composite
currently stands at over $12,000, we’ve
seen a 120X return on this index since inception.
For perspective, the S&P 500 has grown 42X
during the same time period.
Moving onto the NASDAQ 100, this is a conglomeration
of the 100 largest non-financial companies
that are listed on the NASDAQ.
The NASDAQ 100 wasn’t introduced till 1985,
but given that it’s not only filled with
a bunch of tech stocks but also that it doesn’t
include any of the slowed moving financial
stocks, I don’t think you’d be too surprised
to hear that the NASDAQ 100 has already produced
a 100X return.
But, it should also be noted that when we
experience a downturn, the NASDAQ 100 gets
slaughtered.
During the dotcom crash, for example, the
NASDAQ 100 sold of 83%.
So, if you’re looking to invest into the
NASDAQ 100, you definitely need to be able
to stomach some volatility.
Anyway, the NASDAQ composite and the NASDAQ
100 aren’t the only two indices from the
NASDAQ though they are the most popular.
There’s also the NASDAQ Global Equity Index,
the NASDAQ Golden Dragon China Index, the
PHLX semiconductor index, the OMX Stockholm
30 index and so on and so forth.
Moving on from all these indices, the NASDAQ
also has their own stock.
During the height of the dotcom bubble in
2000, the NASD decided to start selling their
stake in NASDAQ.
They started off with a private placement
offering, and shortly after, shares of the
NASDAQ started trading on OTC markets.
And eventually, on February 9, 2005, the company
NASDAQ was listed on the NASDAQ stock exchange.
The ticker symbol for the company is NDAQ
and they currently sit at a $25 billion valuation.
Clearly, embracing the digital world has played
out quite well for them.
NASDAQ VS NYSE:
Alright so, the NASDAQ primarily rose to fame
by embracing technology.
First they embraced electronic trading and
then they embraced online trading.
This attracted a bunch of tech firms to their
exchange and this is how they became super
famous.
But, nowadays, everyone has electronic and
online trading, so why do modern tech companies
continue to choose the NASDAQ over the competition.
Well, looking at it from a common sense perspective,
would you want to list your stock on an exchange
that has lagged in innovation or would you
rather list it on an exchange that has lead
the curve.
The answer is obvious, but innovation is not
the only reason companies tend to go with
the NASDAQ.
Another major reason is cost.
If you want to list 75 million shares on the
NYSE, you’re looking at an upfront $360,000
plus an annual listing fee of $71,000.
If you’re looking to list the same 75 million
shares on the NASDAQ capital market, however,
you will be paying a slightly higher annual
fee of $79,000, but the upfront fee is significantly
less at $75,000.
At this rate, it would take 35 years for the
NYSE to become the cheaper option.
Something else to consider is that the NYSE
also has more logistical requirements.
For example, all companies listed on the NYSE
must have an independent compensation committee
and an independent nominating committee.
NYSE companies must also have an internal
audit function and corporate governance guidance.
As you would guess, none of these factors
are requirements with the NASDAQ.
So, if you’re simply looking at cost, logistics,
and innovation, NASDAQ is the easy choice
to make.
However, a select group of companies continue
to use the NYSE over the NASDAQ for a few
reasons starting with prestige.
As we discussed, the NASDAQ is often associated
with extreme speculation and insane volatility,
and this association puts off a lot of investors.
Also, it should be mentioned that the NYSE
goes out of their way to reduce volatility.
According to the NYSE website, their exchange
is 51% less volatile at the open and 52% less
volatile at the close.
So, companies that are less growth oriented
and more stable like financial institutions
and insurance companies often choose to list
on the NYSE over the NASDAQ.
This natural divide has made the NYSE the
go to place for value investors and the NASDAQ
the go to place for growth investors.
This doesn’t really matter for the end user
though given that both exchanges are offered
at basically every brokerage you can think
of.
NASDAQ EXPLAINED:
At the end of the day, none of the components
of the NASDAQ are particularly hard to understand.
The reason that it’s often confusing is
simply because the same name refers to so
many different things.
It would’ve been way better if each of them
had a different name, but unfortunately, this
is the system we have.
First there’s the NASDAQ company which is
charge of handling the NASDAQ exchange.
Then, there’s the NASDAQ indices which primarily
include the NASDAQ composite index and the
NASDAQ 100 index.
And finally, there’s the stock of the NASDAQ
company itself.
Over past few decades, the NASDAQ has proven
to be the more innovative exchange with much
looser policies which has made them a favorite
amongst growth companies.
But, a lot of companies in legacy industries
continue to prefer the NYSE and that’s the
NASDAQ explained.
If you were the owner of a multi-billion company,
would you list it on the NASDAQ or the NYSE?
Comment that down below.
Also, drop a like if you thought this video
explained the NASDAQ well.
And of course, consider checking out our international
channels to watch our videos in other languages
and consider subscribing to see more questions
logically answered.